من كومبيانسكي ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
مازن ابراهيم مازن مع هذه الضربات الروسيه
الكثيره اليوم باتجاه اوكرانيا ما الجديد
في الواقع ما اعلنته القوات الجويه وقياده
الاركان عن سبعين صاروخا ومشيره استهدفت
الاراضي الاوكرانيه كان حتى السابعه صباحا
ولكن منذ السابعه حتى الان القصف مستمر
بشكل كبير انا اقف في مقاطعه خركاب في
مدينه كوبيانسك تحديدا التي كانت تتعرض
خلال الساعات الماضيه والدقائق الماضيه
لقصف مكثف روسي عند خط الجبهه وايضا في
عمق البلده لعلنا نشاهد من خلال عدسه
الزميل ايلي في هذه المنطقه قامت القوات
الروسيه بقصف مكثف يمكن ان نشاهد حجم
القصف الذي طال كامل خط الجبهه الذي يبعد
عنا نحو ثمانيه كيلو مترات هذه المساحه
المفتوحه والحرجيه التي نشاهدها هي مسرح
عمليات عسكريه ما بين الطرفين القوات
الروسيه ومنذ صباح اليوم تستهدف كامل هذه
المنطقه المحيطه بكوبياسك في محاوله منها
للضغط والتقدم الى هذه المدينه التي كانت
قد استعادتها القوات الروسيه الاوكرانيه
في شهر سبتمبر الماضي عمليا كوبيانك التي
تحدث عنها زيلنسكي بالامس عندما قال بان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت مختبرا للدم
للمتطوعين الذين يتبرعون بالدماء ضمن هذا
الخط لم نتمكن من الوصول الى المنطقه التي
تم استهدافها تحدث عنها لان الجيش
الاوكراني منعنا من التقدم اكثر باتجاه
عمق تلك المنطقه على اعتبار انه اعلنها
منطقه عسكريه لا يمكن لاحد من الصحفيين
التقدم باتجاهها ولكن عمليا هذا المركز
الذي تحدث عنه
تم استهدافه من المرجح بانه قد يكون مركزا
عسكريا او على الاقل للمتطوعين العسكريين
لان تلك المنطقه خاليه من السكان بشكل تام
عمليا هذا هو واقع الجبهه ليس فقط في
كوبياسك ولكن في كامل مقاطعه التي تعرضت
للقصف الروسي يضاف اليها مجموعه كبيره من
المقاطعات في البلاد وغربها نحن نتحدث على
مقاطعات ملاصقه للعاصمه كاف وايضا فيزا كل
تلك المناطق تعرضت لقصف صاروخي الصواريخ
التي تم استخدامها في هذا القصف تحدثت
عنها قياده الاركان مشيره الى نوع انواع
متعدده من صواريخ الكليبر وما الى وغيرها
التي استهدفت لا اعلم اذا كان الصوت القصف
المدفعي يصل من خلال من خلال الميكرو الان
ولكنني اسمع فعليا عمليات القصف المتواصله
تمتاز باهميه كبيره بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه فهي تعتبر احد المراكز
الرئيسيه لمحاولات التقدم التي كانت
تخوضها ضمن النسق الاول والهجوم الاول ضمن
هذا الهجوم المضاد الذي بدا قبل شهرين
ولكن في هذه المنطقه تحديدا استعادت
القوات الروسيه زمام المبادره وهي تضغط
لمحاوله تطويق هذه المدينه والدخول اليها
لان البعد الاستراتيجي بعد كبير من هنا
يعتبر خط دفاع عن مقا طعه لوغانسك التي
تحتلها القوات الروسيه وايضا تحاول من
خلال التقدم الى هذه المدينه اطباق
السيطره والخناق على كامل هذا الخط في
محاوله لمحاصره القوات الاوكرانيه في اكثر
من جبهه واكثر من موقع شكرا لك من مراسل
الجزيره مازن ابراهيم